bonsoir à tous ravi de vous retrouver
pour ce nouveau 78 sport allez comme
d'habitude place au sommaire un mois des
mondiaux de cyclisme sur piste qui se
dérouleront sur le vélodrome national
nous nous sommes arrêtés sur l'état de
forme des coureurs de l'équipe de France
après la Coupe du monde à Cali après
défaite à reins le Sky rugby avait
l'occasion de se relancer avec la
réception de la lanterne rouge bon œil
ce weekend très brouillon les joueurs
cquentinois gagne mais sans la manière
en football féminin Montini a
probablement dit adieu à ses espoirs de
monter ce weekend pour le compte de la
10e journée de Division d'Honneur les
inontain 2e se sont inclinés face au
leader Saint-Denis et évidemment vous en
avez l'habitude l'essentiel des
résultats du weekend enfin d'émission
mais place tout d'abord au cyclisme
et vous l'avez vu sur le plan large de
Romain ruspini à la réalisation il y a
du beau monde ce soir sur la table
autour de la table du 78 sport Yan
dujarriier le consultant cyclisme de
l'émission est présent bonsoir vous êtes
accompagné à votre droite du président
de l'Étoile Sportive de trappe
muststapha Larbaoui on va parler
évidemment de l'actualité du club tout à
l'heure bonsoir Mustapha et notre
consultant handb tous les consultants
toute l'équipe du C sp
bonsoir bonsoir à vous onevendra vous
voir tout à l'heure mes plac je disais
tout d'abord au cycl c'est mond qui
approche Yan 1 mois on va dire 29 jours
précisément puisque c'est ça commence le
18 février prochain et ce jusqu'au 22
février et ce weekend il y avait la
Coupe du monde à Cali une étape
importante et surtout qui remémorait
beaucoup de souvenirs notamment à
François Perville qui s'était imposé
l'année dernière sur ces TER comment
vous avez vu perçu cette étape de coupe
du monde rapidement
dernière échéance avant les avant les
championnat du monde une petite
répétition générale maintenant est-ce
que toutes les forces présen étaient là
je ne sais pas j'ai pas eu toutes les
listes engagé des beaux résultats des
une belle résultat sur la vitesse par
équipe après le reste à confirmer dans
un mois on va évidemment détailler ça je
vous propose de regarder un sujet
justement où on a on s'est arrêté sur
l'état de forme de l'ensemble des
coureur de l'équipe de France à tout
juste un mois de ces Mondiaux à 50 ans
montage de Romain rusp
à un mois de la compétition l'idée
d'accueillir les mondiaux de cyclisme
sur piste ravi toujours autant les
coureurs de l'équipe de France c'est
vraiment la fierté qui prime on est à la
maison va avoir du public les places
sont vendues très très vite donc on sait
qu'il vaoir beaucoup de monde qui va
venir nous soutenir et on en est content
et on attend avec impatience ce momentl
où le frisson quand les gens vont nous
applaudir nous encourager pour aller le
plus vite et donner le meilleur de
nous-même passer ce sentiment de fierté
il faudra réussir ces Mondiaux à
domicile et tenter de de faire mieux
qu'en 2014 en Colombie où la France
avait ramené CIN médailles dont les
trois titres de François Perville
linontin va d'ailleurs vivre son premier
grand championnat dans le costume du
numéro 1 si cela ne change pas son
approche de l'événement il sait que
psychologiquement ce maillot arc-en-ciel
pourrait lui faire gagner certaines
courses on m'attend oui on m'attend et
je pense que bah comme tout champion du
monde on a peur de tomber contre lui
donc moi je sais que quand je monte en
piste suivant tel ou tel l'adversaire je
sais qu'il y a déjà 50 % du du travail
qui est fait parce que lui dans sa tête
il se dit déjà j'ai perdu mais depuis ce
weekend et la Coupe du monde à Kali
l'inquiétude règne dans le camp
tricolore après la lourde chute de Lig
monontin lors des qualifications du
Kerin côté bonne nouvelle privé de
Pervis Grégory boget Kevin Sirot et
Quentin lafarg se sont imposés en
vitesse par équipe avec des meilleurs
temps à leur poste pour les deux
premiers rayur tricolor avec ce trio
l'équipe de France a retrouvé la plus
haute marche du podium pour la première
fois de la saison le staff de l'équipe
de France devra trouver la bonne formule
d'ici au 27 janvier date de l'annonce de
la sélection officielle pour les
Mondiaux on l'a vu dans le sujet Yan ce
weekend François pervi a chuté pendant
les les qualifications du du Kin est-ce
que une chute avec donc une blessure a
priori pas trop grave mais quand même
des brûlures au niveau du genou et de
l'épaule ça peut conditionner ou voir un
peu perturbé ces dernières semaines de
préparation j'ai vu des photos des
blessures je pense pas maintenant est-ce
que par la suite peut-être que la
semaine prochaine on va voir enfin cette
semaine on va voir des des mauvaises
nouvelles bah il peut être handicapé par
la suite maintenant juste des brûlures
ça devrait pas pas être problématique
pour ça maintenant je sais que François
est quand même pas en avance sur son sur
son entraînement sur sa
préparation pour les championnats du
monde donc c'est encore un point négatif
sur pour pour l'échéance ouais surtout
que fin novembre début décembre il a eu
pas mal de petits virus il a été
longuement malade et il a retrouvé sa
forme que mi-décembre en fin de compte
donc du coup c'est vrai qu'il est pas
encore totalement au top donc François
Perville qui chute il n'était pas dans
cette vitesse par équipe qui a gagné ce
weekend composé de Kevin Siro qutin
lafarg et greégory boget une nouvelle
composition mais qui gagne pour la
première fois de la saison ça ça remet
un peu peut-être tout en question ou pas
du tout vous pensez qu'il y a déjà une
composition d'équipe d'arrêté il avait
quand même fait la qualification il
avait participé pour la pour la
qualification il a pas pu faire la
finale maintenant greégory boget avait
fait le deuxè temps lors des
qualifications il a fait le premier
temps sur sur le tour du coup tout sur
tout le tournoi il a fait il a fait le
meilleur meilleur démarrage François
avait fait aussi le meilleur tour et
donc Kevin kevin est réussi à à
compléter le et à rester dedans c'est
vrai que là on a quatre bonhommes pour
trois places on a déjà eu cette
configuration dans des d'autres années
euh moi j'ai du mal à comprendre
pourquoi on met pas François en dernier
c'est quand même le champion du monde du
kilomèt est-ce que voilà on n pas non
plus toutes les toutes les infos moi je
mais voilà voilà c'est vrai qu'une belle
équipe avec Grégory B en 1er Kevin C en
2e François perv en 3e ça pourrait faire
un très très beau très très beau
résultat au
final je suis pas sélectionnaire ouis ça
va être sûrement le C tê dans les
quelques jours à venir de Franck durivau
le membre de l'équipe de France et le le
coach des du sprint français avec
Laurent Ganet ça va être compliqué de de
décider de faire surtout que je veux pas
minimiser la performance de du 3è de qui
était quana FARG voilà qui voilà il est
là il a a largement sa place mais c'est
vrai que là ils sont quatre et c'est
c'est très très compliqué est-ce que
vous pensez que ça peut être trop
compliqué de faire mieux qu'akali il y a
un an en 2014 et c'est CIN médailles ces
quatre titres ramenés de l'autre côté de
la planète il y aura 5000 personnes qui
seront là peut-être pas 5000 français
qui seront là pour les soutenir non je
pense que je pense qu'ils vont réussir à
faire de très très beaux
mondiaux on a on a une certitude c'est
que François va peut-être avoir du mal à
prendre trois titres ça c'est ça c'est
vrai euh mais moi je suis agréablement
surpris par donc greégoryi qui qui qui
revient comme ça là pour pour faire le
meilleur temps sur sur le premier tour
euh il nous reste un mois je dis pas que
dans un mois grégoryi pourrait pas être
champion du monde loin de là quoi
l'autre coureur dont on parle toujours
un petit peu moins c'est Thomas bouda
pourtant pétri de talent il fait 5e sur
l'Omnium ce weekend il est dans la
continuité de sa saison est-ce que le le
podium est toujours envisageable dans un
mois à 50 Anseline sur ce type d'épreuve
quand on est dans un top 5 c'est un
podium qui est envisageable lui je pense
que son objectif c'est pas le podium
c'est c'est le titre il est certainement
encore en en période de préparation il y
a pas de il y a pas d'inquiétude à avir
c'est il est il est il est pas son
niveau mais il est il est là pour le
combat quoi il y a pas de pas de
problème je je pense qu'il va faire
encore un beau un beauonde championnat
du monde et encore ça êre encore les
travaux d'hercul comme d'habitude pour
pour l'homum et mais bon ça va être ça
très beau tournoi à suivre aussi chez
les femmes la bonne surprise si on on
peut dire c'est Sandy cler qui qui fait
une belle 4e place sur le le tournoi de
vitesse individuelle bon qui n'a pas
confirmé hein derrière sur le Kirin ça
peut être un espoir de médaille parce
que bah les médailles françaises chez
les féminines ça fait un petit moment
qu'on les attend sur les Mondiaux il va
falloir qu'elle s'appu là-dessus pour
peut-être justement aller chercher cette
médaille no niveau mondial sur sur le
King et sa sa discipline de
prédilection maintenant on verra aussi
les résultats de Virginie Virginie cuff
ouais la championne de France
tout à fait donc qui était pas Cali mais
qui je pense devrait devrait aussi
pouvoir aller se se battre au niveau
mondial pour les Championnat du Monde
Mustapha j'aimerais vous faire réagir
justement vous le le local de de trappe
quand vous avez un vélodrome comme ça
tout près de chez vous du club aussi
voir ces athlètes de haut niveau
s'entraîner et puis se préparer pour ces
Mondiaux c'est quelque chose
d'exceptionnel pour le l'amateur de
sport que vous êtes alors pour l'amateur
de sport que je suis ouais évidemment
parce qu'en fait je peux écouter pendant
des heures les gens parler de leur sport
et effectivement dans les détails c'est
vrai que je maîtrise pas simplement on
retrouve les fondamentaux du sport et
les fondamentaux du sport c'est à la
fois un cadre de la rigueur et en même
temps de la proximité c'est on est
vraiment en relation avec les uns et les
autres là on voit bien que on parle
technique on parle de résultats mais on
parle des hommes on parle de performance
on parle de travail et dans des temps un
peu troublés comme aujourd'hui je trouve
je trouve qu' on on oublie le sens de
des fois des choses que l'on fait et le
sport est une apporte des valeurs
exceptionnelles à des notions très
simples il faut revenir à l'objet
l'objet du sport l'objet al que ça soit
le cyclisme que ça soit le football que
ça soit le handball que ça soit toutes
les tous les sports possibles euh encore
une fois on en revient à des notions
très simple et souvent la plus grande
difficulté c'est de faire simple et ça
nécessite beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de
travail donc ouais j'admire parce que je
me dis que nous aussi on arrivera à ce
niveau de performance que en restant sur
l'objet en restant sur le sujet dans la
rigueur et dans la proximité donc ça
m'intéresse de les écouter je comprends
pas tout je suis pas au courant de tout
mais en même temps en même temps voilà
c'est c'est c'est aussi un message
d'espoir et je profite d'ailleurs de
l'occasion pour dire que cette émission
et et vous en particulier venir nous
chercher comme ça sur des valeurs
positives des valeurs positives de ce
que représente le sport mais de de ce
que représente aussi les clubs et ce que
représente également les allez on va
dire que ça soit trappe ou que ça soit
les les quartiers dont on peut parler
tout ça ce sont des valeurs positives
sur lesquels on peut rester
fondamentalement et encore une fois je
remercie TVfil d'être à l'écoute de ce
genre de discipline toutes les
disciplines il y a beaucoup sur la table
autour de la table en tout cas ce soir
c'est clair pour revenir un petit peu
justement sur les Mondiaux une dernière
fois y est-ce que le premier succès en
fin de compte de ces Mondia 2015 c'est
pas déjà que le bah le vélodrome sera
plein quand la billetterie était ouverte
en quelques heures déjà presque tout
était écoulé c'est un premier succès
mais je dirais que à chaque fois qu'on
organise quelque chose sur ce vélodrome
et ben on s'aperçoit que le public est
là et j'espère qu'il y aura beaucoup de
cquantinois beaucoup de loogos parce que
parce que ce sera quelque chose de de
génial très très très beau un très très
bel événement et je pense pas que bah
sur 50 ans on est régulièrement on est
souvent des championnats du monde quel
que soit la quelle que soit la
discipline un mot sur Vélodrome qu'on m
interrogé sur le vélodrome pas la
discipline mais sur le vélodrome c'est
un endroit superbe il y a beaucoup de
choses à y faire on y fait pas
simplement du vélo il y a d'autres
manifestation et j'invite les gens à
venir découvrir ce lieu parce que moi
j'ai découvert ce mur en en tour en
regardant les gens tourner c'est
fascinant à regarder c'est voilà et
c'est on passe d'un sport à l'autre mais
c'est également des vrais événements à à
et moi je et moi je les invite même à à
juste venir réserver un petit créneau de
d'iniit pour un baptême et ils verront
que c'est impressionnant quand on est en
haut et quand on est en bas et qu'on
tourne finalement c'est pas si difficile
je pe a testé je l'ai fait et c'est vrai
que c'est beaucoup plus abordable pensa
qu'il inviter ses copains à venir au
foot également he parceil faut qu'on
fasse aussi rendez-moi l'appareil j'ai
un peu de mal merci y pour cette
expertise encore une fois sur sur les
Mondiaux restez avec nous parce qu'on va
parler d'autres sujets et on passe
évidemment au handb avec
Alexandre place donc à notre consultant
handbal Alexandre rebonsoir merci d'être
passé sur le 78 sport ce soir on va
parler de Montini et de votre équipe la
team 78 ans championnat de France moins
de 18 ans tout d'abord Montini donc chez
les féminines National 2 les monages ont
frappé un grand coup ce weekend face au
leader AVR en allant s'imposer au Havre
sur un score de de 30 à 6 on ne peut
plus éluder la question maintenant
Montini est carrément favori presque
pour cette montée non favori je sais pas
mais en tout cas c'est sûr qu'ils ont
réellement créé la surprise en allant
gagner les leaders
elle s'impose elle progresse on se
souvient en début de saison on en avait
discuté elles avaient mal démarré et on
s'était dit bon ce n'est que le début de
saison attendons de voir que il y a un
nouveau coach à se mettre en place et
cetera et cetera le projet de jeu donc
ça se met réellement en place maintenant
encore une une fois la saison est longue
et c'est pas parce que on bat le leader
et on en est qu'à la moitié de la saison
que la montée est assurée loin de là
donc il faut continuer sur C
cette cette dynamique de victoire ça
c'est très important pour la confiance
et pour faire peur aux autres aux
adversaires continuer à gagner et puis
on fera les comptes à la dernière
journée parce que bien souvent on sait
que pour une montée ça se joue jusqu'à
la dernière journée il faut rappeler
hein là les matchs retour viennent tout
juste de débuter viennent d'enchaîner
quand même deux performances
notable puisque la la semaine passée
elles ont elles ont battu vmomble à à
domicile qui est aussi dans le top 4 on
a vu le le classement tout à l'heure et
est-ce que cette réussite en tout cas
cette dynamique de victoire c'est pas
aussi la la réussite de l'entraîneur
Philippe létrange qui a succédé on sait
à Stéphane paysan et qui a peut-être
insufflé un quelque chose de nouveau au
sein du club ce qui est sûr c'est que ça
veut pas dire qu'il a un entraîneur qui
est meilleur que l'autre mais il est
clair que quand un entraîneur fait un
certain nombre d'années il est des fois
important dans dans pour la continuité
de la réussite d'une équipe de de
changer alors ça peut être changer
d'entraîneur ça peut être changer un
certain nombre de cadres de filles aussi
là en l'occurrence a surtout été
l'entraîneur et et bon voilà ça peut
insuffler une nouvelle dynamique voilà
et et en tout cas jusqu'à maintenant
c'est c'est le cas mais de toute façon
Montini c'est c'est un objectif qui qui
que le club a depuis très longtemps de
revenir en
n1ès Ann donc c'est dans la continuité
et je dirais que c'est le les résultats
des fil d'aujourd'hui ce n'est pas que
le résultat de l'entraîneur de cette
année mais c'est aussi le résultat de
l'entraîneur qui était Stéphan avant
puisque ce sont grosso modo les mêmes
joueuses donc c'est une forme de
continuité après peut-être que
l'entraîneur le nouvel entraîneur un
siifle un sufle nouveau qui permet de
passer ce petit palier supplémentaire
mais c'est c'est vraiment une addition
des des deux à mon avis et pas le
résultat que d'un et pour parler des jou
justement vous en disiez un mot cette
année peut-être par rapport à la saison
passée où tout tout reposait presque sur
la capitaine Gabrielle parlo et puis une
ou deux aéèr là le danger vient de
partout cette saison c'est peut-être
aussi ça qui fait la force de Montini
tout à fait de toute façon il est bien
évident que c'est plus difficile à
contrer une équipe dont le scoring passe
par plusieurs joueuses que par seulement
une ou deux joueuses donc forcément ça
participe à leur à le à leur réussite et
et et c'est en général quand même
quelque chose de plutôt bon signe de
pouvoir se reposer sur plusieurs
joueuses que sur seulement une ou deux
joueuses auquel cas il y ait méformes
maladie blessure ou mesformes du match
euh bah peuvent quand même avoir une
certaine forme de sécurité pour gagner
des matchs qui sont qui seraient donc
plus difficil à gagner sans une ou deux
bonnes joueuses qui qui serait en en
perdition lors d' d'un match en
particulier on passe aux hommes au
jeunes hommes les votre équipe la team
78 alors là vous aveit débuté cette
deuxè phase du championnat de France
moins de 18 ans plutôt difficilementin
on va pas se se cacher Alexandre par une
défaite donc à
créteille sur un une lourde défaite 53 à
32 euh comment vous vous voyez cette
saison c'est la saison de la
confirmation à ce niveau pour vous bien
qu'il a eu déjà la première première
phase moi comme je vous dis je vois
cette saison comme une saison avec un
nouveau projet puisqueavant on parlait
d'un club maintenant on parle d'une
entente c'est la première entente créé
pour le handbal dans le
78 donc rien que ça déjà c'était une
réussite de réussir à le
faire et puis maintenant on l'a vu par
rapport à la première phase on a fait un
meilleur début de saison que l'année
dernière euh il va falloir confirmer ça
sur la deuxème phase j'ai confiance en
mes joueurs euh on se reprendra au
prochain match le weekend prochain là
qui arrive euh on a rencontré les
champions de France en titre au complet
ce le weekend dernier euh ça n'excuse
pas l'écart du score la déf en plus est
un est un club professionnel à voilà la
défaite est est normale il faut pas non
plus se cacher mais le score est trop
élevé euh maintenant euh on va corriger
certaines choses euh notamment en
défense on va récupérer tous les joueurs
aussi pour le weekend prochain ce qui
n'était pas le cas contre contre Créteil
donc voilà maintenant il faut que les
joueurs s'organisent pour se remettre
dans dedans tout de suite et et livre un
match avec un gros combat contre
l'entend su 93 un dernier mot avant de
de passer au rugby évidemment mondial
oblige l'équipe de France a commencé sa
campagne du côté du Qatar par deux
victoires pas pas si facile que ça ces
deux victoires comment vous jugez ce
début de campagne cette phase de poule
des Bleus alors moi je pense que
l'équipe de France faut la juger un peu
différemment des autres équipes parce
que c'est une équipe qui gagne quasiment
à chaque fois donc les débuts de
championnat je peux peut-être
interpréter une forme de lassitude des
joueurs contre des équipes de moyen
niveau la République tchèque leségypte
c'est pas des équipes qui iront jouer
les demi-finales sauf si je me trompe
mais je ne pense pas donc donc voilà il
y a peut-être une certaine forme de
lassitude et ce qui compte c'est gagner
ce qui est pas mal c'est qu'ils ont
mieux joué contre l'Égypte contre
République tchèque et heureusement parce
que c'est plus fort l'Égypte par contre
il faut quand même qui réhaussent leur
niveau parce qu'ils vont commencer à
rencontrer une équipe notamment la Suède
dans pas si longtemps que ça qui a quand
même mis 14 buts à la République tchèque
n on a mis que trois donc si on veut
arriver en deuxème phase avec le maximum
de points c'est-à-dire il faudra battre
la Suède pour après se qualifier en demi
il faudra livrer un tout autre match
contre les sudis si on si on veut gagner
ça c'est clair et net très bien merci
beaucoup Alexandre d'êre passé sur le 78
sport on enchaîne sans transition rugby
je le disais après une défaite à reins
le Sky rugby avait l'occasion de se
relancer ce weekend en recevant la
lanterne rouge de sa poule bon œil très
brouillon hein c'est peu de le dire les
joueurs cinquentinois gagnent mais sans
la manière résumet réalisé avec un
montage de Romain
ruspi les matchs entre un candidat à la
montée et une équipe condamnée à la
relégation sont souvent des pièges pour
les favoris et face à bon œil le Sky
rugby est tombé dans la la tenaille
pourtant tout avait bien démarré pour
les joueurs de Guillaume paayen qui
avaiit ouvert le score sur un essai
collectif des avants mais alors que le
Sky maîtrise plutôt bien son sujet le
tournant du match arrive peu avant la
mi-temps coupable d'une faute d'antijeu
volontaire le deuxème ligne de bonœil et
Cope logiquement d'un carton jaune qui
se transforme en rouge pour contestation
les joueurs du valdeemarne vont devoir
jouer plus de la moitié du match à 14
contre 15 et c'est à partir de cette
expulsion que le Sky rugby va entrer
dans un fau rythme multipliant les
fautes de main et les imprécisions les
cinquantinois se font peur et voir
revenir bon œil au score même à 13
contre 15 il aura fallu attendre les
toutes dernières minutes de jeu pour
voir David Martini plonger dans l'en but
suite à ce ballon porté des avants avant
une dernière banderille de Jérémy
Barbier à la 80e minute qui scellerlera
le succès du Sky rugby 27 à 14 le club
seïe à la 2e place mais sur la pelouse
de Montmorency lors de la prochaine
journée il faudra montrer un tout autre
visage pour rester dans la course à la
montée je sais pas pourquoi parce que il
a plus d'espace qu'il sont à 14 puis
plus d'une mi-temps et même quand il son
à 1 onarrive pas à enchaîner on fait
nouveau despes quand faut garder le
ballon on fait des mauvaises passes des
mauvaises réception et plein d'reur
technique qui fait qu'au final les
erreurs techniques font qu'on arrive pas
à scorer quoi jamais donc donc jusqu'à
la fin ils y croi ils peuvent prendre un
bonus
défensif encore une fois on est bien
content d'êre à la fin cétait vraiment
pas croyable
9e après 11 journées de championnat en
promotion d'honneur les objectifs de
podium un petit peu annoncé sur ce
plateau en début de saison sembleent
bien loin pour l'Étoile Sportive de
trappe miné par les blessures notamment
le club va sûrement devoir sauver les
meubles cette saison et pour en parler
de cette reprise 2015 le président
Mustapha Larbaoui est présent bonsoir
Mustapha bonsoir première question vous
avez donc gagné pour une reprise un
petit peu compliquée un petit peu
spéciale en tout cas 2015 après les
événements qu'on a connu à Charlie Hebdo
c'est important de débuter cette année
2015 par une victoire alors c'est
complètement déconnecté des événements
c'est toujours important de de gagner
des matchs donc toute façon on est là
pour les gagner tous c'est important de
les gagner tous maintenant on sait très
bien qu'on ne gagne jamais tous ces
matchs pour des tas de raisons ensuite
une reprise et effectivement un moment
particulier donc c'est bien de pas
louper le départ en début de saison voir
euh une reprise à la en mi-saison donc
voilà tous ces CHL toutes ces choseslà
sont importantes je vais quand même
corriger quelque chose si je peux me
permettre hein j'ai annoncé en début de
saison que nous allions chercher
probablement la montée et le podium
j'avais les éléments pour le dire on a
l'équipe et globalement les forces en
présence on les a vu sauf que c'est
comme dans le on a parlé du hand tout à
l'heure on a parlé de de de de on parle
de différents sports ici on en revient
touj à la même chose c'est une question
d'homme c'est une question d'alchimie
c'est allez pour pour employer des
termes un peu un peu osés mais l'grégore
ne fonctionne pas forcément tout le
temps et donc c cette alchimie qu'on
recherche ben voilà par exemple à cette
table je disais qu'on aurait une
difficulté parce qu'on avait pas
grandchose dans les dans les dans les
filets si je peux me permettre
l'expression gardien de voilà on a on a
trouvé quelqu'un d'exceptionnel il a
fait un match extraordinaire le dernier
il s'est cassé le bras vendredi avant ce
match de reprise donc on était encore
une fois lui handicapé et toute l'équipe
l'était mais vous l'avez quand même
annoncé sur ce plateau en en septembre
que cétait l'objectif et voir faire
monter les deux équipes avec donc
l'équipe prère la rés jeue sauf que je
continue parce que si on a un match de
retard donc si vous regardez le
classement avec un match de retard ce
match gagné de retard ça nous met à 5
points du leader c'est tout à fait
jouable en en
football je peux me permettre je pense
que pour aller chercher la lune il faut
viser les étoiles donc ça sert à rien de
se mettre des limites dans les objectif
autant viser très haut et puis bah après
on récoltera ce qu'on pourra mais voilà
pour pour pouvoir chercher je dis
toujours à quelqu'un qui veut chercher
le podium il faut viser la première
place en tous les cas des objectifs faut
les fixer faut pas que ça soit non plus
des vœux pieux il faut que ça soit
réaliste aussi ça l'était en début de
saison on regarde après les forces en
présence aujourd'hui je continue à le
dire c'est encore faisable sauf que on a
plus de retard qu'en début de saison
pucequon a des points de retard mais
vous n'avez pas peur comme l'année
dernière en fin de compte vous aviez
annoncé à peu près les mêmes objectifs
il y a un an et demi sur ce plateau et
au final vous avez fini dans le ventrre
mou du championnat là est-ce que vous
n'avez pas peur de faire bis repétita ah
mais B étit pendant des années on monte
pas tous les ans tous les ans en
revanche on a des objectifs tous les ans
on a des désirs tous les ans on veut
s'imposer parce que c'est la compétition
qui veut ça c'est je dirais même
l'essence même des sports c'est de la
compétition en revanche se dire que on
va monter alors qu'on n pas les forces
en présence alors là ça ne reste qu'un
vœux pieux mais je suis pas du genre à
faire des vœux mais globalement vous
êtes en train de dire que vous n'avez
pas réussi votre recrutement de l'été
c'est un peu ce que vous êtes en train
de dire là non al c'est le recrutement
était parfait sauf queil y a des
accidents encore une fois sans rentrer
dans tous les détails le gardien est un
accident très très notable il y en a eu
d'autres sans rentrer dans le détail ici
mais il y en a eu d'autres mais c'est la
vie d'équipe qui est importante c'est la
vie de groupe et donc les vœux non des
objectifs qui sont fondés sur des choses
très réalistes et tenables dans le temps
oui après les accidents je les prévois
pas mais je continue à dire que c'est
jouable mais on Mona ni tous les ans
mais je vous garantis que on se reverra
à d'autres émissions autour de cette
table pour les confirmer ensemble très
bien merci beaucoup mapha on est un
petit peu pris par le temps évidemment
et le format de l'émission merci d'être
passé sur ce 78 sport on suivra
évidemment avec beaucoup d'attention
cette petitêtre monté alors de trappe
podium de trappe en fin de saison on
enchaîne juste dernière info foot
féminin en reste dans le football
Montini je le disais dans les titres a
probablement dit adieu à ses espoirs de
monter ce weekend pour le compte de la
10e journée de Division d'Honneur les in
Montain 2e recevait samedi au stade de
la coudre le leader Saint-Denis dans ce
qui ressemblait un petit peu à une
finale de cette C poule même si les
joueus de jeanan Grosset ont plutôt
maîtrisé leur sujet et ont rivalisé sur
le plan de l'impact physique elles se
sont faites surprendre dans leur temps
fort notamment par la vitesse des
attaquantes de SC saint qui ont étté
très réalistes score final 4-2 en faveur
des visiteurs il y a encore du travail
pour retrouver la division
2 déçu parce que c'était le vraiment le
gros match de de la saison je pense
qu'on a tellement parler de ce match par
rapport au match aller que
là j'ai pas de mot en fait c'est là
c'est vrai que ça ça met un coup moral
il faut continuer à travailler c'est
vrai qu'il y a des petites jeunes il
faut continuer à bosser et PE préparer
l'avenir c'est une équipe très physique
de toute façon la DH la région
parisienne c'est ça c'est très physique
faut être près physiquement aujourd'hui
je pense que on a perdu on a perdu cette
bataille là
physiquement c'est la fin de ce 78 sport
merci encore une fois de l'avoir suivi
excellente soirée sur
TV